a federal judge has ordered accused
Russian agent Maria butanna to stay in
jail until her trial
Poochyena pleaded not guilty in court
yesterday to charges of conspiracy and
acting as a foreign agent prosecutors
say she contacted Russian operatives
while in the US and used her cover as a
gun rights activist to gain access to
conservative politicians Paula Reid is
at the US District Court House in
Washington with the latest Paula good
morning good morning
federal prosecutors accused Bettina of
being a federal agent who offered sex in
exchange for a job where she could
influence US policy and she was arrested
Sunday after years of allegedly carrying
out a scheme that reads like something
right out of a spy novel I'm a
representative of Russian Federation 29
year old Maria boo Tina seen here in a
sexy GQ photo shoot certainly looks the
part of a Russian spy Betina came here
on a student visa in 2016 but the
Justice Department alleges she took
steps to develop relationships with
American politicians in order to advance
the interests of the Russian Federation
photos show her with NRA CEO Wayne
LaPierre
and Republican governor Scott Walker we
meet people they introduced themselves
often they ask for a picture and that's
not a meeting she sent this photo of
herself near the Capitol during mr.
Trump's inauguration to a Russian
official who responded calling her a
quote daredevil girl she also tried
unsuccessfully to arrange a meeting
between President Trump and Vladimir
Putin but she did manage to get in a
question about sanctions too then
candidate Trump at Freedom Fest in 2015
investigators allege boo Tina had an
ongoing relationship with a 56 year old
political operative strictly for
business purposes and was likely in
contact with Russia's FSB intelligence
agency throughout her time in the US
Eric O'Neill is a former
counterintelligence operative with the
FBI
a spy will do whatever they can to get
that information and if they got to
sleep with someone to do it they'll do
it
a Russian Foreign Ministry spokeswoman
says betina's arrest is all part of an
effort to undermine US Russia relations
that the FBI moved in to arrest her
after it says it's a sign she was
preparing to flee the country including
packing up her apartment telling her
landlord her lease was going to be up
and transferring $3500 to a Russian bank
account
fionna all right Paula Thanks